nur wenige Schritte sind es vom Erfurter
Weihnachtsmarkt zum Schuhgeschäft von
Mechthild Betz dadurch hat sie gerade
wieder etwas mehr Kundschaft doch
meistens bleibt es beim Gucken
Stammkunden und Online-Shop halten den
Laden noch am Leben sagt die Inhaberin
das staatliche Hilfen und preisbremsen
angeht da habe sie aber mittlerweile den
Durchblick verloren ich finde es sollte
weniger geregelt werden und das was
geregelt wird muss einfach erklärt
werden können aber es ist so kompliziert
ich habe aufgehört nachzuhaken das zu
verstehen und nach zu fragen bei wem
muss ich mich jetzt wo melden um da was
zu bekommen so dass ich nicht nur auf
mich selbst verlasse vor vier Monaten
waren wir schon einmal hier ihren
einzigen Mitarbeiter habe sie inzwischen
entlassen müssen berichtet Beats dafür
hilft nun Tochter Mathilda regelmäßig
mit in ihrem Sortiment setzt die
40-Jährige auf Fähre und nachhaltige
Produkte um davon auch wieder mehr an
ihre Kunden zu bringen bietet sie
erstmals einen Advent an das bedeutet
dass ich aktuelle
Kollektion also aktuelle nur jetzt von
Herbst Winter schon reduziert habe
vorfristig weil die nicht verkauft
wurden für mich ist es schwierig weil
noch teurer im Einkauf die
herstellerkosten sind gestiegen meine
Marge verringert sich weil ich sie jetzt
zu einem reduzierten Preis verkaufe doch
selbst der Sale Preis bei vielen Kunden
inzwischen zu teuer ein Phänomen das sie
zuletzt immer häufiger beobachte es gab
einen Tag jetzt in dieser ganzen
Adventszeit der sich so angefühlt hat
wie vor dieser ganzen coronazeit und
Schließzeit
ansonsten ist es ruhiger und
überschaubarer und sehr durchwachsen und
heute kann ich sagen
ich glaube ich kann es an zwei Händen
abzählen wie viele Kunden drin waren und
zwar bisher jetzt ein Schuh und eine
Socke die ich verkauft habe
die mageren Vormonate haben nun auch das
Weihnachtsgeschäft nicht ausgleichen
können weshalb ihr finanzieller
Spielraum quasi aufgebraucht sei
Riesenrad Glühwein und Co gönnen Sie
sich deshalb dieses Jahr auch nicht die
Früchte mit der Schokolade überzogen die
sind bestimmt um zwei drei Euro
gestiegen und es ist
[Musik]
nicht mehr meins weil ich finde den
Genuss dabei hat man da nicht mehr so
wenn man weiß das wie viel Geld man aus
gegeben hat gerade bei den
handwerklichen Ständen die müssen ihre
Standgebühren natürlich zahlen können
und die Materialien sind teuer geworden
das kenne ich durch meinen schuhgewerbe
aber das heißt auch wieder wie bei einem
anderen dass ich und dass wir immer
überlegen müssen
[Musik]
können wir uns das leisten einer Tanne
gibt es dieses Jahr auch nicht ein
festliches Gesteck soll reichen
der Weihnachtsbaum ist mir zu teuer
sonst müssen ein paar Zweige hier halten
mit einer Amaryllis ein bisschen
Weihnachtsschmuck dran und außerdem ist
es so dass wir umziehen Ende des Jahres
und dann haben wir auch einfach kein
Platz mehr die Sachen von Sohn Leonard
sind schon in Kisten verpackt er macht
gerade ein freiwilliges soziales Jahr in
Ghana jetzt sind die Zimmer der Töchter
dran monatelang haben sie an allen Ecken
und Enden gespart trotzdem kann sich die
alleinerziehende Mutter die Wohnung
nicht mehr leisten das ganze ist einfach
ein Mietpreis der so exorbitant ist dass
ich gucken musste und jetzt haben wir
eine gefunden die womit wir uns zwar
sehr verkleinern sind 50 Quadratmeter
weniger also wir müssen
wieder auf sehr beengtem Raum
Zusammenleben aber wir sparen eben auch
wirklich mehrere hundert Euro im Monat
wegen der gestiegenen Energiekosten
läuft die Heizung hier erst seit Ende
November und auch nur im Wohnzimmer in
Urlaub konnten sie dieses Jahr nicht
fahren und an Weihnachten gibt es auch
nur Kleinigkeiten Alternative ist Umzug
und ein neues Zimmer und eine neue
Wohnung und die ist für mich
zufriedenstellend und ich freue mich da
total drauf und deswegen bin ich da
nicht so traurig ich finde es auch nicht
schlimm wenn man nur irgendwie ein
Geschenk hat oder so zu Weihnachten man
kann das ja auch wertschätzen dass ihre
Kinder so genügsam sind erleichtert
Mächte Beetz die aktuelle Situation und
die Entscheidung die Sie treffen muss
fürs kommende jahrhofft sie auf mehr
Planungssicherheit beruflich wie privat
und auf einen Heiligabend unter einem
richtigen Weihnachtsbaum